Dolores? Run, run Dolores. Do they have Dolores? They got her. Oh my God, they got Oreo.
My home is being terrorized, my animals are being slaughtered.
You could hear them in the trash can,
thumping around trying to get out,
trying to get air, trying to breathe, trying to
survive.
This is not right this is not just, and this is not humane.
These are my pets, these are my kids pets. Dear God, they're all dead. Everybody, they're all dead.
Backyard chicken owners are a passionate breed. At first we thought chickens were just dumb chickens,
but you do fall in love with them. I would play chase with one outside and he'd bite me, and take off running,
then come back to me, and oh we'd play. I'd sit on the ground and talk to my chickens, maybe,
a lot of people think that's crazy but those chickens understood.
I have a few old ladies that they have house chickens. Their chickens live in the house with diapers.
Kerri Hand is a retired cop who lives in rural Riverside County, California.
She became a chicken owner for the eggs but then she fell in love.
This is where I would sit, right here. Pretty view, and the horses, and having the birds.
It was just very relaxing to me. As Hand's family grew so did her flock. My 13 year old son,
he's a war buff, history buff, so for this kids 13th birthday he wants a Civil War Turkey.
That's Dolores, was her name, and she literally stole the hearts of many. She would jump on you,
like she was a parrot. When you go sit outside she'd hop on your lap she
had her little leash the neighbors loved
her with Walker in December of 2018 and
returned home to find an ominous notice
stuck on her door it was from the
California Department of Food and
Agriculture and it said there was an
outbreak of a highly deadly avian virus
in her neighborhood very little castle
disease has been diagnosed in Southern
California protests in the Inland Empire
over the killing of thousands of
chickens euthanized doctors say to
prevent a virus from spreading
birds infected with virulent Newcastle
disease and their eggs are perfectly
safe to eat but the virus can wipe out
massive flocks and
state and federal health officials had
ordered all birds across several
counties under immediate quarantine
including hands over the next year and a
half officials searched thousands of
homes and farms and identified just
under five hundred infections after
deciding that quarantine wasn't enough
they ordered the mandatory euthanasia of
over 1.2 million birds in high-risk
areas surrounding infections including
healthy Birds that tested negative for
the virus as the euthanasia teams began
to spread out in early 2019 hand created
a Facebook group called save our Birds
after reading numerous horror stories
from those targeted and started
organizing volunteers to show up at
kills and film on their phones this is
so outrageous I can't make it up people
literally if you tell them about this
chicken problem they will look at you
like you are a crazy
these measures may have been necessary
to prevent the spread of the Newcastle
virus but according to the bird owners
who spoke with reason
health officials carried out their
duties in a cruel manner leaving bird
owning families with lasting emotional
scars hand complied with the state's
quarantine orders for months and paid to
have her birds tested by a veterinarian
but the state ordered the destruction of
her flock anyway the news came by way of
another notice stuck to her front door
in April 20 19 it has a box checked that
they were gonna be coming to kill my
chickens hand decided to challenge the
order since her Birds had tested
negative for the Newcastle virus just
that week and remained fully quarantine
I've complied with you I I haven't done
anything my birds aren't sick the state
responded with a surprise operation as
hand and her family were preparing to
celebrate Good Friday a team of police
and state workers dressed in biohazard
suits arrived at her house with a search
warrant and in order to kill her
family's flock it was like it looked
like a drug raid is what it looked like
we are going to humanely euthanize these
birds today and recorded and shared live
video of the slaughter in her Facebook
group save our birds and it went viral
my birds are dead the deputy goes gets
the big bolt cutters they could cut my
fence apart Oh Dolores which was the
first what are the first ones they went
after and they grabbed her she was very
friendly she would come when you called
her and they literally like grabbed her
by the neck and like swagger I'm not
sure if they snapped her neck or not but
they might have they threw away the
trash kid I need you relax
they don't the way you hit is workers
kill birds by breaking their necks
shooting them with firearms or
suffocating them with co2 gas methods
that officials maintain are humane but
hand disputes that claim she recalls
that workers placed her birds in a trash
can with no viewing window forcing them
to lift the lid to check if the birds
had died each time oxygen leaked in
prolonging the process the floppy and
you could hear the birds crying like a
squawking to get out and this sounds
like you can't unhear those sounds my
kids you could hear him in the house
screaming out the windows I have a metal
container in my backyard and you could
hear like the pinging of the bullets or
gunshots like pinging off of it I mean
my horses are just running Oh like dust
everywhere it was like it's like a like
a nightmare movie that I couldn't even
make it up
they left feathers they left a little
bone part after God they're all dead
everybody they're all dead after her
video went viral hands Facebook group
became a place for thousands of local
bird owners to share information and
support one another it just kind of
evolved into hey if they show up
we'll come be there for you I'm here I'm
another side again but you want to know
why our healthy chickens had to die
Gena crews got chickens as therapy
animals for her sons one of whom has
autism and fragile X syndrome and the
other PTSD from combat my son with PTSD
would go out there and feed them every
morning religiously and talk with them
and grab them and hold them and say oh
my baby and to each and every one of
them Cruz consented to her pets
euthanasia despite the fact that
officials had found them negative for
Newcastle as long as the process could
take place while her son's weren't home
but when state workers arrived at her
house for the scheduled appointment
reporters and members of hands safe our
Birds group were already there filming
they abruptly left she tells me what is
this circus she says we're gonna
reschedule
Gena we're gonna reschedule the next
week several police cars unexpectedly
pulled up to Cruz's house her son with
PTSD was home he came out and he watched
his chickens his babies be killed so I
went and I said my goodbyes and and my
think used to them for for all the joy
that they had brought to our family my
son with autism there's not a day that
goes by that he doesn't ask for them and
asked me to ask the bad guys to bring
his chickens back han says that her
teenage son is wracked with guilt that
he didn't do more to save his beloved
Civil War Turkey Delores in the bathroom
crying at school so people wouldn't make
fun of him when he tells me he thinks he
hears her and he tells you he goes
messes with my mind hand and other
members of save our Birds alleged
they've documented scores of abuses by
state workers and police they killed
about six to eight of the gals Pitts
stopped told her they were at the wrong
house
left they won't leave the paperwork with
you to review or if you don't speak
English or you can't read it they tell
them we're gonna come back with the
warrant and break your locks and come on
your property if you don't sign this
right now this is true then I need about
when they stepped on the baby junk
what'd they say over there oh it was
human error human error look what you
did and then they left it there to die
as a former cop hand is also troubled
that courts are handing law enforcement
vast powers to target innocent bird
owners they're treating it as a criminal
nature warrant but these people aren't
criminals none of them I don't
understand it I've never seen any such
warrant there's no property description
there's nobody's name and it basically
gives them the rights to go to any
property they want to go to in Riverside
County months after hand and Cruz's
chickens were disposed of state
officials have continued to search their
properties using the same administrative
warrant even when they're not home
they've already come back for a recheck
there's a hundred and twenty day period
they say they're gonna come back up to
ten times twice fully suited and go
through the yard to make sure we haven't
restocked the safe our birds members
also say they've been subjected to
surveillance for months they try to get
neighbors against neighbors they go into
other's backyards to try to look around
going by very slow staring at us taking
pictures taking video I'm in a red light
huge peoples on next week I Roger how
you doing we're like this all the time
you know that's a hell of a way to new
animal health officials who declined to
speak with reason have defended their
actions on the grounds that backyard
chicken enthusiasts practice lacks
biosecurity and exacerbated previous
outbreaks of Newcastle in California and
that they faced intimidation from
members of hands Facebook group
we make it say is that the group here
starts to get a bit rowdy and they start
making our people and they intimidate
the USDA says it's allocated 45 million
dollars in emergency funds for the
Newcastle response but California
officials have declined to say how much
they're spending it isn't believable the
amount of manpower and force and
officers and people and cars I mean the
whole totality of it all
officials currently have no plans to end
the quarantine and the euthanasia
campaign continues any kind of
information any kind of transparency we
need that and without that we've lost
trust in them in their tactics their
bullying and their inhumane echinacea
and and her core group of volunteers
have pooled their resources to contest
the state's warrants but the outlook is
bleak
you're on your own these chicken killers
they don't care what they got a turn
easy that's the government I mean
they've got all this money yeah they got
all this money and I got upset with him
out there cuz I says you know what I
fought for your freedom I fought for my
country and I almost got killed I says
so that we could live free and live what
you know live how we want to we were we
don't break no laws we don't hurt nobody
and it's it's bigger than just a chicken
because what's next what are you gonna
come to my house and come barreling in
here for they continue to film and
support targeted bird owners but they
live in fear of California's animal
health officials sign right here you can
either sign if you fail to sign you're
gonna be taken into custody you know
come on Kerry I'm a nervous wreck every
Dodge Ram that I see passed by I believe
is them I don't know if I'll ever be the
same for me that day it changed a lot
because the system I believed in the
badge I want swore the oath I took the
integrity I thought that officials had
and and what we're supposed to trust you
can't
you